hey helmet hi martin what's going on
i built a cloud run service and i
noticed it's slower for users in
australia
than for users in the us uh could you
help me fix that
sounds like you might need to put your
cloud run services closer to your users
i can show you how
[Music]
ok my web application has a sign up form
with a city field
as the user types into the city field
they will get auto complete suggestions
from a cloud run service
that sounds good martin and i deployed
this service to the u.s central one
region
when i access it from my house here in
california i get response times between
70 and 80 milliseconds
i'm pretty happy with that but you're
saying this service is slower for users
in australia
yeah this is what happens when i access
the service from a virtual machine i set
up in sydney
uh there you see here the responses are
much slower
just over 200 milliseconds why is that
happening amit
right now your cloud run service is
running in u.s central one which is in
the iowa data center
people in australia are so much further
away from iowa than you are so naturally
their requests will take longer
for many applications this is not a big
deal if the response times you just
showed me are acceptable
you can keep serving all your users from
one location
but for some interactive services like
your autocomplete service
every millisecond counts so your users
in australia would see a better
performance if you could take this
autocomplete service
closer to them this means you need to
deploy the same cloud run service to a
google data center in australia
okay that sounds great but how do i
configure my cloud run service so i can
route them to the nearest google data
center
you don't have to the google cloud https
load balancer lets you use
global anycast ips meaning wherever the
user connects from they're routed to the
nearest
google data center and then the cloud
load balancer will route the request to
the nearest cloud run service that you
have deployed
okay let's do it but i'm an application
developer
not a network admin are there any
instructions for this
yes i just sent you the link to a
webpage that describes the process
basically you have to set up an ip
address a tls certificate
then tie it all together by creating a
load balancer okay
let's see pulling it up here it looks
like it's just a list of g
cloud commands looks like i can enter
the names
of my services uh copy the commands
uh and then i just run these in my
terminal yeah that's right
also you need to update the dns records
for your domain name from your registrar
to send the traffic to the ip address
that you just created it's all in the
instructions
cool i will run these gcloud commands
and update the dns record
uh it can take a while for dns to
propagate uh
see you back here in 30 minutes sounds
good
all right we're back uh what now let's
first make sure that you haven't broken
anything for users in the us
do you want to make a request uh yes uh
let's see
trying it out now from here in
california
ah there okay good it's still working
and it's still fast
excellent now let's check if the
response time has improved for your
users in australia
okay pulling up the web page now
entering the first letter of a city name
yeah that's a lot faster before it was
over 200 milliseconds
now most of these requests took less
than 20
and it shows here that it's serving from
a data center in australia
but ahmed why is sydney faster than what
i get from my house here in california
good question this is because the
nearest deployment that you have right
now is in u.s central one which is in
iowa data center
you could deploy this to us west 2 which
is in the los angeles data center to get
even better response times from your
home
in fact there are no downsides to
deploying all available regions because
you pay a fixed price for the load
balancer and since cloud run charges you
based on the requests
there is no downside to deploying your
application everywhere
all right so my current deployment is
working well for users in the us
and in australia right now but what
happens if a user is
in another place let's say singapore i
haven't deployed my cloud run service
there
google's load balancer is smart enough
to route them to the closest cloud run
service that you
have deployed behind the load balancer
why don't you try it
okay i set up a virtual machine here in
singapore
let's see opening the web page uh
oh it looks like they get just over 100
milliseconds response time
and here we can see the data was served
from the cloud run service in sydney
nice and if you don't want to run a lot
of gcloud commands to deploy this
application manually you can write a
terraform module and easily deploy your
application to all regions
we'll put a link in the description for
that oh cool
uh but ahmed what about my users in
antarctica
a serious question do you mean the
researchers and the penguins
maybe we'll get to it someday ah yes the
penguins
everyone thank you so much for watching
please leave the comments below and
let us know if there are any other
topics you'd like us to discuss
[Music]